hey guys welcome to another swish water
lead podcast episode unfortunately the
Tes and Marco season is now over but
that does mean I will be able to get an
episode out every Monday again until the
end of season three a massive shout out
to swash for still supporting the
podcast even though coaching commitments
had to come first very grateful to them
so go and support swish by getting
yourself or your mate your very own
personalized video from one of your
favorite sports stars and with the
women's Rugby World Cup around the
corner it's an awesome time to get one
from one of our black Fern Legends like
Porsha Woodman Ruby Tui or even the
great Woodland guest Kendra Cox Edge
remember that up to 70 of the proceeds
do go to Kiwi kids Charities and that if
you use the code Waterland you can get
15 off your order so go get amongst that
also the great Palm always coffee have
created the perfect coffee bean for any
lad and has packaged it up as Waterland
coffee freshly roasted here in Nelson
you can even go and watch them get
roasted at the coffee factory in Stoke
if that's your thing these are the best
coffee beans in the market they're
available in whole bean or espresso or a
plunger and you can get 20 off your
order by using the code lead 03 I'll
leave a link in the description for easy
access so go get yourself your very own
water layered coffee also one of New
Zealand's best harness trainers Regan
Todd from Todd's racing have an
opportunity of a lifetime for you to own
your very own piece of water lead in the
form of the soon to be Champion horse
water lad this guy looks a real treat
and looks to have all the speed of his
dad Lazarus I'm hoping to get behind him
soon so I can really feel the speed in
the sulky if you're interested flick me
a message on Instagram or if horse
ownership's not your thing at least go
follow Todd's racing on Facebook where
he will give you an insight to his
weekly Runners anyway grateful to all
our sponsors but let's get to this
episode
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Wanna Live
[Music]
oh what a lead well it's not often you
get someone who has literally died on
the field while playing a game of rugby
but today that all changes today's guest
is a legend of the South he starred with
the Southland Stags and the Highlanders
for many years he also spent some time
over in Wales with the Newport dragons a
brief stint in Melbourne with the rebels
and of course he played for the New
Zealand maori's on top of that he's also
coached the Stags Honda heat in Japan
and he's now currently coaching the
Tasman Marco he is a seriously good land
it is Hawaii McDonald welcome home thank
you very much
mate is this your first podcast very
first is that right I was trying to find
a podcast on you to sort of do a little
bit of you know research but first
podcast with a story like yours that's
incredible oh no pleasure to be here
amazing your story like literally dying
on the field you think you'll almost
think a movie's being made out of it so
far no that's a funny thing baby like
Thomas moved on into the boys this year
coaching them nowadays until kind of a
few Whispers been around they're kind of
like what's going on yeah so it's it's
awesome how rugby just kind of just
flows out yes mate it does move quickly
hey like you're a legend what five years
ago and now no one knows yeah
that's that's um no it's a cool game
like I even talked to the to the boys
about like past players yeah past been
like five years ago and they wouldn't
have a clue who's talking about yeah
yes some of these like young kids like
the you know not hothams and stuff are
they like you ask them I do know Jonah
Loma or something oh not really like how
do you not know this guy that's it
that's it
who's that
okay now you you're used by pretty quick
eh but let's get let's start from the
start with you Hoon I know you know so
many people you're a you've got a
massive family
um did you where'd you grow up so I grew
up in uh invercargill
um but my dad was a mess family in
Blenheim so oh yeah so it's how we ended
up back here before the with all the fun
out there and your dad that was a
massive family hey what was it how many
kids how many uh siblings sit here he
was one of 21. 21 yeah so it's pretty
the net goes pretty wide so I said well
we've got over 100 first cousins true
yeah so it's pretty crazy what was it a
bit about as um he had 21 kids but 17
were worth well because my granddad had
two wives so sisters so he had his first
with the Forfeit of the first wife and
then 17th of the second but the second
wife was to say my my grandmother's
sister was looking after the kids so she
just fell in love yeah that's crazy
that's cool though it's really really
cool but you kind of walking around
Blenheim and it's
like everyone's a cousin like I wouldn't
even know yeah but then it's it's kind
of crap because I grew up down south but
all my cousins out there they know
everyone it's like Corner McDonald any
relation yes I think our grandparents
are siblings so my grandfather took his
Grand
would you know all your cousins no no
chance no chance sure and how many um
siblings have you got
um so I'm one of well my my dad was kind
of saying a lot more Granddad he had a
seven and then seven of the first wife
and then my mum three with us so she's
got ten and yeah so it just keeps going
again
I mean where do you sit on a little
child of the three
that on the baby oh baby yeah sure yes
I've got two older sisters but then I've
got four older brothers and three other
sisters so and did you all live together
up together no so so we moved down south
so we were down south the three of you
you and your two sisters oh yeah yeah
but then a couple of my brothers moved
down there too
so I kind of grew up with him oh yeah
but they're a bit older than me so it's
kind of yeah it's funny I've got nieces
and issues that are older than me and
some of us and every time we have a few
drinks or something like that if I'm
getting a bit cheeky I'm sucking called
Uncle
so how did you get into 40 and when did
that all start
um I was a bit of a late bloomer really
um I grew up playing basketball and
other sports and then um it's about 15 I
started playing rugby
and that was just because the boys at
school talking about rugby on Saturday
so I thought I'd give it a crack and
then yeah I was I was talking and I
could jump and bet they could lift and
line out so you know first thing coach
see you come on in and sure we went we
go to basketball oh
well yeah there he is
basketball from about 17 for Southland
um for the men's senior men's and then
kind of went up made a New Zealand
divisional team that's right yes it was
awesome it's it's a cool game I still
try to play as much as I can because
yeah so but yeah I play basketball right
through
even when I was playing rip for the
stakes and stuff like that to play a
great basketball was that sort of your
dream at that time to become a oh yeah
yeah big time so it was a well we had a
really good group of mates that we all
got coach same coach and taught us all
how to play really good basketball so
all of us will kind of hang out and the
dream was to head over to the states and
you know but yeah it's just what stop
that wait dear can you cut off if you
went home no no no no no no no I would
have probably been able to play ebl or
something like that but
yeah rugby kinda
kind of just took over
the early 20s but I was still playing
still playing like I played Club in the
morning senior seniors at night but
representing basketball tonight oh yeah
yeah so it was good fun and I think you
know looking back
that was probably how I became
professional right play I reckon yeah
like a lot of the skills aren't
impossible right load management or
none of that none of it yeah the
correctional load management yeah oh I
get it but mate we were playing I was
playing four games basketball weekend
again rugby on Saturdays yeah and
training twice twice a night every night
you kind of just know yourself tissue
injuries nah it's coming to what I
reckon
so when did rugby take over and it
started to become the main thing so I'm
gonna play in the eighth grade I went to
a small school in invercargill so
there's no age group footy or anything
like that
um I'll play Southern rips and stuff but
in terms of New Zealand that and then I
went to Varsity and then when I was
playing varsity when I was at varsity
um once I've finished I've got an
opportunity to to play for the stakes
then and that's what started the ball
rolling so I done next season being was
I made the homeless development and then
ended up being a replacement player for
the holidays and then after that so I
played the game for the Hondas Maybe
special and then got the phone call for
New Zealand maoris they were going over
to Canada a couple of weeks later and I
was so you're in it yeah far out yeah
did you feel comfortable or how do you
feel going into those environments no no
not all I will no not really the the
reason I failed a bit at ease with us
because uh when I went up to the Honda's
the first time I was with Clark and
Daniel quite and a few of the boys from
down south Jimmy oh yeah I was in the
flood they just put me in the flat with
him and so they were kind of running me
through and uh their experiences was
Unreal living right there oh no just the
whole the whole you know when you get
that phone call to say I need you to
come up to Donna's yeah
because we've got a couple of injuries
all you know yeah and I was just thought
punching this thing we wanted to
calculus I was talking to the cows just
like so pumped then got up there and
then um clacking them so I'm super
excited and Clark who's younger than me
he's been in that room a couple of years
so he's kind of just tempering me down
yeah yeah and then um yeah went up to
Auckland for a game and shot a few of
the boys went down quite early and then
like I'm looking at Clark he's looking
at me like oh you're wrong
got out there and you know you're
playing against those guys you've been
watching on TV yeah yeah and catch Muses
and like and giving me alarm and all
this stuff and it's just yeah
and obviously went pretty well
um well I only played well one half and
then um and then after that New Zealand
molding selected and they're kind of
gone that ranking system so and then one
of the boys they'll go to Canada and one
of the boys had a had a charge
um yeah it couldn't go so I was like
then we'll get the phone call from
Mexico and we're getting pumped but I
think me and me and Jake Paul
with the only non-super every players
there really yeah and um oh it was just
amazing what is it like in that
environment hear different stories eh
yeah yeah well back then it was like
really social but the boys yeah like so
it was really social but once you step
over the line the boys are on and it was
like and uh keeping each other really
accountable
get off the field and then this guitar
straight away and you're on and so they
had they had a really good balance and
um but it was just like fun you know
like rugby was fun the rugby we played
was fun
um they kind of wasn't like it was a bit
of structure but
May of course he see a half again then
they're going for it and anyone's kind
of running off themselves it was really
good for as a young guy and then I just
got told just get out there and Skip
busy so yeah it was awesome and sort of
all your teams you play for the Stags
Highlanders the maoris and all those
teams seem to have a pretty good balance
of um fun off the field as well
especially going from some of the
stories from the likes of newbie and
Elliot Dixon and these sort of guys
sounds like both those environments are
pretty
um there's plenty of stories that happen
off the field yeah yeah it's quite a bit
happens off the field it's it's good fun
oh really good fun and then uh
a lot really fond memories of my times
with uh with the Hondas and the stakes
and in the maoris and in anything else
but I suppose any team you play for
there's a certain level of fun that you
know has speed yeah head off the field
you know he was young guys in an
environment like that you know like
there's bound to be a few laughs but it
was like maybe there's some really good
times down the South so that is real
good times any stand out for you
um you would have had a few Shield
successes and stuff did you no no I went
over to Wales
we had one opportunity we played
Auckland and we kind of
the year I went to Wales
the boys went up the Christchurch and
got the job done
and they're all like even males sitting
there watching it online and well I you
know it was really really special and I
was around the coaches and it's so
pumped for them and the team and oh
that's wicked
but before that I wish this sister
like just have a lot of fun and what I
noticed most was there was never really
any trouble but I think
right there's no camera phones either so
how did it get caught the guys went
silly enough I don't know I understand
what God's kind of record all that stuff
and yeah post it seems a bit odd but
yeah some of the stuff that the boys got
up to you know she's like
so why'd you go to Wales what was it
um
like it was just an opportunity to go we
uh I was gonna I was getting a bit on a
partner wants to get out of invercargill
yeah so it's just to go see the world
because you know she's been with me for
the whole time I was playing rugby sales
about six seven years and just kind of
going from Dunedin
and so um so she was pretty Keen to go
over so I'm always Keen to go have a
look around too so opportunity came up
and where we went and I was awesome UK
travel and just experiencing different
different environments is good we're
ever close to being in all black
I've got a trial I got injured but I was
um unavailable for a trial they had a
trial in 2005 before the Lions tour and
so I was meant to troll on that
um and then I've got the next year I
made the New Zealand the junior All
Blacks oh yeah so I made that team
um but I got rung up yeah I'm in the mix
and I think
yeah I think it sold the dream but I
thought oh [ __ ] this could happen so I
kind of hung around for a couple years
and in hindsight you know you've got to
pick your moments and then would have
been time to take off but I don't regret
it I love playing with those the junior
All Blacks team was we had a rock star
team yeah Rockstar team so much fun
and then when you move to Wales how do
you find it over there I was it was
different it was different it was just I
suppose the same
uh you go to different cultures and they
just train differently their ethos is
different
we were kind of the poor cousins of of
Welsh rugby so it was quite interesting
our training facilities and stuff for it
was quite strange yeah we're training on
like about a three-quarter field it was
it was really weird in the middle of a
kind of cycling Village run so why'd you
go to Newport like what was the deciding
factor to head to that club
um oh no there was the opportunity that
came up you know I suppose you know like
uh at that stage
and we wanted to go over to Europe and
yeah it was pretty much gone you know to
where the money was yeah and that was
the best deal on offer for like two plus
one and then um but I got rang up pretty
quickly by uh Paul Tito I said hi don't
live in Newport live in Cardiff and I
was like sure it is yeah they live in
Newport yeah and when I got there I
could see why I was pretty it's a pretty
pretty rough holiday so you lived in
Carter I love the cartoon the card of
favor which is awesome yeah yeah but so
I was a bit of a commute so we had about
45 minutes commute every morning
I've lived with a couple of Lids that
was also playing with
um on the same apartment complex with a
couple heads who are playing
in Newport we even Tom Willis and Ben
Castle all those boys are there too oh
yeah but yeah so we just
it was pretty much the reason why in the
Newport but I wouldn't have any other
way he's going there now I was I made
some really great mates that you know I
still keep in touch with now and on the
field was there a massive difference
yeah yeah it was slower age like
um we played a super Open Season I left
it was it was like pretty much any
infringement at the rack was this a free
kick oh that's right yeah so it was a
step and go playing Super Rugby so
you're kind of always on the go so and
so as soon as you hear a whistle you
start kind of running yeah or getting
back
and they got over there and then there
was a troll they do in New Zealand got
over there and I was like whistle and
I'm just kind of like let's say they're
slam it down kick it kick it to the
corner or whatever
so it was a lot slower that's what I
felt but the way that they trained over
there too was was different it was
pre-season not much Fitness going on
it's all weights they just want to be
bigger
and so it was it was just a different
game that they played did it suit your
style or not really and uh well it
didn't it didn't the first year because
I was a lot fitter but then in the
second my second year they just kept
trying to make me get bigger and then I
was so I was kind of saying I need to be
fitter this my game isn't yeah the power
game it's about being a bit more loose
or a bit more agile yeah you know we
want you to be big so put me on all this
this program and eating all this food
and [ __ ] and I just so I started doing
my own running yeah and then the trainer
caught me
yeah how did it so I was I just keep
trying to just get any running I can and
after training start doing extra
sessions and stuff and things like that
I didn't really enjoy it that much but
still they were only out there every
week and well sales it was a good
experience
but it was pretty tough at times too
really yeah and did you feel like you
learned heaps as a as a rugby player
obviously different styles there you you
sort of into your own sort of bubble
here in New Zealand until you get
experience different
um different styles of play yeah oh big
time and then and that's what I had to
get my head around was
I think coming from New Zealand
you kind of think that this is the way
the only way yeah so I was questioning
everything we were doing I was like well
what are we doing like that yeah and
then like is it easy to do it like this
yeah and they're like I can see where
you're coming from but nah
okay and then so I keep asking questions
and then I got to the point where I was
just like no I'm not even going to
bother and so let's just let's just do
it yeah and it was all right you know
like um like we were kind of punching
above our weight for in a couple of
Seasons so but uh I do think that it
could we could have done things better
and then why did you return home what
was the reason to return home you'd made
your money yeah or um there's a few
things going on
um the old lady got bit sick and uh
you're like 30 hours away 30 something
hours away over there so we kind of
started um uh an opportunity to come to
go to Melbourne so we we signed in and
then I'm only a couple of hours away so
that was a big big part of the reason
and then from there we just ended up
coming back to New Zealand after that
we're kind of yeah we've done what we
want to do we've got a heap of travel
and we could see the world
and um at a really good time too so well
that's good how was Melbourne yeah
Melvin's awesome where was Rebels was
awesome I was there for the first year
and uh was this the very first year of
the rivers yeah right first year and um
mate they spared no expense on that year
it was kind of weird it was these
dinners and like what's going on here
they shattered the whole all the
families out to this Resort and he runs
into it and no 20 dinners yeah
it was like 20 drinks kind of things it
was just it was insane sure and we were
all kind of like is this the way it is
yeah like this Australian rugby or
somewhere but apparently no and you know
after I left I was talking to the boys
how good is it and I like mate they're
tightened it right so
um no I think we've got sport that those
first couple years we had some real
Legends of Australian rugby too that
like Sterling walk locks and Rob my
queen was a coach and
um El Campbell there was quite a few
boys in there that were like wallaby
Legends so they had to kind of
like look out for them and treat them
really well well yeah it was the first
time it was in Melbourne too and
Melbourne's like a pretty cool City yeah
they would have wanted to do it right
new stadium new themselves the first
um yeah Amy Park so it was awesome what
was um Sterling mortlock like it's it's
a good dude yeah really good dude he's
out there though yeah he's out there
snooky yeah so um but just on the field
super intense yeah and then off the
field just not not who you would think
if you talked about yeah but awesome
dude like uh they all were all the
Aussie boys was really good fun and what
other kiwis did you have join in that
first year there's a few eh yeah KIVI
O'Neill he was the Yoda so I forget a
couple
um oh but there was like Jeff delve from
Wales
oh yeah he was there
um and then they've got a couple of
leggies in and stuff so Jared Safi he
was playing for St George illawarra at
this stage and yeah he was a nears it
was a bit the bunch yeah it was cool
yeah um Mike Lipman saw a video on him
the other day actually and it was pretty
sad to see what he's going through with
his dementia did he have any signs or
anything of it early earlier on not at
all like lipo was he was a he was a good
dude being a really awesome team man
um hard case could see the choppers on
him
and uh but he was yeah oh it's just sad
yeah doing all that you know that's
something that's starting to come a bit
more apparent to now yeah with you or no
how do you yeah sometimes I feel like it
is yeah like uh that's I don't know I
don't know like we when I was playing
you kind of you did you gotta knock
and if you could kind of shake it off
then you're good to go and you keep
going yeah sometimes I think you know
like when I think back should I should
have walked off the field then I'd known
myself that I wasn't right yeah but you
kind of you want to keep playing yeah
and then
even after the game you're not right but
you're kind of hide it so that you get
to play the next week yeah and I think
what they're doing now and the play has
been more aware of it I think it's it's
awesome because it's a big issue and
we've got to look after ourselves and
and players go look after themselves so
hopefully we can they keep making
progress in that area too is to kind of
make it more safer how many concussions
dear can you hear oh I hate yeah I
reckon I had a few I can have quite a
few
um over 20. yeah yeah all right easy
yeah 50. well I don't know
but yeah
but it's um yeah oh it's an issue it's
an issue but hopefully they get there
they get it right and and we can look
after the players to
so the game's a bit safer for them too
because we want to see all the boys out
in the field and like we have some
issues with it this year with the Marco
and we'd heaps hey what was it like 14
concussions or something crazy
I think we can coach coach a bit better
like me looking back I reckon we can
yeah
to try to help them out help the boys
out
but it's um it's a it's a it's a
physical Collision dominated game yeah
sometimes Sports is not going to get a
ride here what is the key to avoiding it
obviously there's a there'll be a few
rugby players listening to this so you
could save about a thousand lives just
from this advice no oh I reckon I reckon
you've got to get your tackle technique
right and I reckon you've got to do
something you train like we and we do we
tell the boys you've got to get in front
of people you've got to stop them win
the game line
um but I think you know they can the
more they work on their tackle technique
to get that right
the safer they become and you're not
always going to get it right but that's
just that's just the contact sport but I
think the more that we can
the more that we can train good habits
and Tackle technique yeah um clean out
the same yeah I think they're better off
the boys will be is there a trend that
you've seen from players around their
technique which has caused The Knockout
so I don't know might be dropping the
head or something like that yeah often
it's a big one dropping like boys kind
of like they spot a guy they get in
front and then there's this kind of duck
and just go yeah yeah and like once you
once you drop your head you lose sight
of the of the guy you're trying to be
trying to tackle yeah and if he moves a
bit then you're not going to get it
right and you might not get it right by
swinging around him and hit someone else
or he runs straight into here so I think
the longer you keep your eyes open and
you hear it up
the better you'll be that's that yeah
I've honestly reckon yeah yeah because I
was talking a couple of boys and I was
quite surprised that they didn't when
they watched it
ask them for their thoughts oh
they really thought of it but yeah it's
it's something that I think can be
taught from a young age too I think even
the junior coaches first in coaches yeah
yeah they've got a responsibility to the
players to help them be better in that
area or you're teaching the masses
through the podcast this is the way to
save their lives
but then from the rebels so you did one
or two years at the rebels just uh one
one of the rebels and then come back and
I and I jump back in with I was a wider
group member of the with the Hondas but
I was about
33 34 then still feeling good at that
stage yeah
um yeah I kind of I felt I felt good I
felt fit but the game was like I came
back here like the rebels was okay but
when I come back to the Hondas yeah it
was so fast
and then the expectation on tight
forwards and and the you know what they
need to be doing I was like holy [ __ ]
like this is really this has really
changed and but I really enjoyed it
because I've I think the game got a lot
simpler but
but man the expectation was unreals you
know that's what it is now it's just
been more and more so was it way faster
from when you left you reckon with the
you know how he's talking about those
quick Taps and all that do you think the
game really sped up or did what you're
going over there you sort of changed
your pace because you're playing a
slower brand or I think it was a bit of
both yeah I think um I definitely got a
bit older and I didn't feel as quick as
when I came back as when I left was fit
but also I just felt the game is just
getting faster and faster and faster and
the balls are getting bigger and just
it's it's I don't know when it's going
to stop me yeah it's working
just watching some of the boys training
and how we're like making them shift
around yeah expectation yeah
wow how do you reckon you go now in your
Prime you're still dominate of course
I don't know like I'll look back I'll
look back on on my career and and I
think you know because I was a bit of a
late bloomer I don't know if I would
have played pro-opiocric and I would
have just kind of gone through the
cracks and oh yeah yeah like because you
know boys can pick that
this game and like play Super Rugby at
20 yeah you know if you're not in their
system it's yeah
and then obviously the the big moment of
your career
um the heart attack on the field so this
is when you playing for Southland how
old were you must have been what 34 4
34. and it sort of what what do you
remember about it talk me through it
um what do I remember I remember there's
a little big blackouts from that day
um I remember warming up
for the game so I don't really remember
the trip up or anything like that or
going to the ground but I remember the
warm-up and then during the warm-up
cabbage and Whopper decided to Chuck a
funny contact drill into our warm up for
some reason
so I've done the first drill and it
looked Bend in the head and I was like
this kind of got shaken up
and then so I looked around I was like
oh no I'm out they're saying I walked
down looked over at the um post and his
tumble is doing his leg swings as he
always done when it was a bit of a
training so I hoped over with him and I
looked at him and I was like shaking my
head and he's like oh my go near there
so I was just affords actually they were
doing this and then um so we started
leak swinging on the post and then um I
remember playing
and we had a really good we had a really
good
um plan so what I mean we had a really
good plan around the line out the
animals working against counties in the
semi and then about ah a bit into the
game I remember plans just been really
out of breath yeah and then got to a
line out and I was just like oh come on
man like you fit in the mess yeah what's
going on and then um
and then done the line out and then we
were making our way to
uh the next rack and then someone
dropped it so I was kind of halfway
there and I was dropped to my knee and I
was like oh man I feel [ __ ] and then the
doc come on see what's going on I'll say
oh now it's I don't know I just can't
breathe I just can't breathe and he's
like oh you've got a head knocker in
that I've got a head knock I just can't
breathe I don't know what's going on
and then he's like oh we'll take you off
for a head knot and I was like I was
kind of getting wild or something I
haven't got a head knock I just can't
breathe I just need to get my breathe
and then um it is online I can't we'll
get you off and then I stood on me but
now I'll be right and I stood up and
went to walk to the scrum
and then just that's it that's all I
remember true collapse and then I woke
up a couple days later
an hospital with wives or hanging out of
me and just
kind of looking around like what the
hell's going on
a couple of days later so they put me
into a from what I've been told so on
the field the paramedic was there
and it was all the stars kind of aligned
all sales got online for me to be still
here talking to you but under in the
paramedic kind of got me off the field
and then something wasn't right he was
trying to he's trying to figure it out
and so he just thought oh [ __ ] I'll just
put the pads on and see what happens and
I said shock him so he shocked me
and then I was doing a bit of CPR on the
sideline and then they got me in the
ambulance
and then there was a parameter there to
put me into a coma
got me to the hospital and then I was in
a comment for a couple of days
and uh yes like a
one percenter like yeah to still be here
like one percent yeah that was because
it had to happen to anywhere else
yeah gone well I thought I'd gone for a
run up on a hill or something like that
would be here but so it's really lucky
and like even the um paramedics still
came in touch with the pyramid Gary if
you're out there and he said
even if I had a like everyone said even
the head it happened at another ground
or wherever it was okay
your chances aren't that high all right
that's so scary eh yeah well yeah but it
was scary for everyone else yeah because
that's more scary for your wife oh kids
yeah well they'll be on them like my my
boys my two boys at that point and one
was one and
two and a half and then um but she was
down invercargill oh yeah and I was in
pocoy and like when I think about well
she had to go through because she
couldn't get up that day she had went to
the next day and yeah they were telling
her and then even when I got to the
hospital
I'll sell only a 20 chance to survive on
the night honestly right so it was
pretty
pretty manic oh yeah but I was him
asleep oh yeah how'd you go on something
I was obviously up to it everyone else
went through all this
and then when I woke up and got told
that was that was pretty tough but
but yeah was it literally for you was it
just did it feel like a sleep is that
what it feels like because obviously you
literally died
did you feel your spirit or anything
leave yeah how religious are you like
now I'd like to I'd like to say you know
have a big story about seeing a life on
the tunnel meet God yeah and he said
it's not your time but um but now I was
I was kind of like I was just out to it
and then but I remember I remember
waking up and seeing my Rugby manager
Rob Nicole was there and it was a doctor
and
um wife was gutted because she said I
woke up and she was there and I remember
she said oh you were talking to me about
Staffing yeah and I was like I can't
remember so she's got it she wasn't the
first person to sing Rob Nichols
nickel was there and then um it was yeah
it was it was pretty out of it but yeah
I went through the emotions afterwards
yeah well it happened because I was just
like [ __ ] and they told me oh you've had
a heart attack and I said what no way
yeah no chance and then they will kind
of get all emotional and I was noticing
because then I'd go no chance and I'll
be like real angry and yeah and like
this and then I go and then I'll look at
myself I go what's going on so I was
like a goldfish for about about five
minutes that's how me yeah I'll go
through those emotions and then that um
tell me let's see they told me about
four times sure because I was just my
brain was just fine back up yeah
and did you have any other sort of side
effects from it like initially nah so it
was a bit it was a bit of memory loss
um
I was here to take it slow
uh well obviously I've got a I've got an
implant in you know um so if my hike is
in a bit of strife because we're in
shock but I was I couldn't
so once I got there and planted contact
Sports around
um and then
kind of just be aware and be away really
do they know what caused it nah this
that's the annoying part I said I don't
really know
well there's definitely an issue but but
they don't really can't really say what
causes they've done it I've done every
test that in the Sun but it's just um
yeah so something that you've got to
live with and and I am living with it
it's it is what it is just kind of move
on has it changed your life like how's
it affected your life in terms of what
you can do other than contact sport like
um everything else normal oh yeah yeah
or I think so like yeah I still try to
train and keep healthy and and eat as
good as I can trying to eat is is fun
I'm a motto
um you know really pushing push myself
to to try you know like
we can't do like a marathon with like
trying to I started training for a
marathon the few years back and like
went for a checkout for the doctor and
he's like oh you would have been up to
I'm sorry man I'm actually trying to do
a marathon you know he goes stop doing
that that's probably the worst thing you
can do it's just concentration on your
hat what are you thinking I was oh okay
so I just stopped doing it yeah but then
yeah still um yeah to try to save the
play basketball uh over in Boone with a
few of the kuzzies would play in the in
the competition over there and touch and
stuff like that so it hasn't really
stopped me from doing too much it's more
just an awareness really yeah are you
allowed to get your heart rate up as or
is that sort of something you're trying
to avoid no I'm allowed to get it up
um but but even down then it's just for
some reason it just triggers and I can't
get under control but without just
stopping so
so I got a shock the other day playing
basketball
to stand out why I was just I had a
weird feeling all day and so when I get
those weird feelings this one I've got
to stop but I enjoy playing so I'm
trying to get past it
and when it can't when my heart can't
get back under control by itself then
I'll get a shock oh yeah yeah and then
what happens once you get your shot it's
like a British Air like a whole lungs
can fill up because what happens here
it's kind of like you I'm painting yeah
yeah and then both failure
let's say and then you kind of but it
kind of sends you once so you kind of
it's like been punch in the chest
when it happens
but I mean it feels good afterwards it's
kind of cool but it sucks because you
know what's coming like now I know it's
coming yeah and I'm sitting there just
waiting waiting waiting and then
it's just it's just something that's
just you have to live with hey it's
crazy so are you under are you on any
more risk now of suffering a another
heart attack or now that you've got that
in place you're probably just as safe as
a normal person oh I'd say a neon B
that's what doctors say anything neon's
safer than because whatever normal heart
attack it was a shock me like once my
hand slows down or anything like that
it'll just shot me back on or something
so something else that's happening yeah
then I'm okay but yeah so so no extra
risk other than the condition that I've
already got yeah which I don't know but
this is definitely something going on so
what what's the options for the
condition have they got any ideas what
it could be no nothing no so I I go on
to like atrial fibrillation so the top
chamber of my heart just starts pulsing
and fluttering yeah and it doesn't get a
full pump of blood through the system so
it's just so one time that happened was
years ago I thought I could get under
control like I said to my wife mate that
because I got a shock yeah Andy and I
said oh I had to give me another 30
seconds I reckon would have got to be
kind of controls it needed to just calm
down oh yeah that's and then um so she
wouldn't ask the uh the lady that was
looking after me down invercargill
because I've got to Monitor and um she
said it got up to about 360 beats yeah
yeah
so then like she came back and said
you're an idiot if you think you can get
down under control
so the next one I realized like I've
actually got I have got an issue and so
I was kind of it was good for me really
yeah because before then I was kind of
really in denial about what actually
happened did you know you have any sort
of heart difference when you were
training obviously you probably wore
heart rate monitors and stuff did yeah
yeah right either no way over 100 or
whatever no no I never really noticed
noticed anything at all really yeah
oh no I don't know I was definitely I
was definitely slowing down by the time
I got the photos
on the preview for the party was um
there was I think one of my defining
moments when I knew [ __ ] me and my
time's coming around real quick chasing
I remember that moment chasing daddy
thinking I was proud of myself being
able to catch especially other forwards
being able to catch me yeah I was
putting that up and I remember watching
the review of that they've been seeing
like I'm like watching through tape and
I was review of the game and I'm putting
it in and he's kind of looking around
smiling that's what I know you man time
is coming [ __ ]
mate how do you do that to most fours or
pretty much any four of the most backs
to be fair so like you're not alone but
then obviously after that incident rugby
was over did he have any plans in place
for post footy or how hard was that for
you to go from you know instant
retirement
um
oh well I started my last season was
Stakes I started kind of going to the
coaching realm
um signed signed back with the Stags and
then talked to David Henson who was the
coach at that time yeah they would I'd
always talked about coaching after rugby
and so kind of went back and said Peace
coach so started doing it as I was
playing and then
so the year after Connor just fell into
it but I was working in the marketing
department at rugby Southington
um trying to trying to sell the dream to
the local local businesses and stuff so
but it was it was a good experience too
like no one actually where the money
yeah to put the team on the field as is
coming from is not just you turn up and
all your gears all kind of always going
to be there yeah the lock is taken away
if you're not
I don't know if it's sponsorship from
the businesses so when did you think
coaching did you know you wanted to
coach when you're playing like early on
yeah yeah I did I talked to a performing
over Foreman overseas I talked to um
song kahane and David Henderson about it
you know because I was had a real
interest in in how how you can kind of
be quite strategic on the field with
within how you play and just certain
skills and stuff like that need to be
uh needs to be taught or coached and so
I always had an interest in it and then
by the time I came back
here at this corner fell into a really
was I was stoked it was cool and then
what was the progression so you did that
one year when you're playing playing
coaching yeah so that was it's tough
yeah it's real tough
because you've got to live by by what
you're trying to do and everything about
it you know so and then the year after
with training the coaching which I
thought would have been easier than what
it was even even the years following
down south because he's still
still playing still coaching the guys
that you've been playing with yeah and
and I'll I suppose I had a bit of a
uh a reputation down there like you know
with yeah like I've always enjoyed
myself the special performing overseas
always enjoyed the field Antics yeah
yeah yeah like with the boys and stuff
like that once you get the coaching it's
kind of
you know you've gone through the dark
side
you kind of try to try to rain all that
in you kind of question why people are
doing it but then and they'll find it
back or hold on Hawaii
so then um and then yeah my comeback is
always oh the games changed yeah yeah
but but and that was that was pretty
tough and the more the more you keep
coaching
you know the further away you kind of
have to pull yourself away from the
players which I found tough too at that
point yeah so so those first couple of
years in terms of the of the
relationships with the boys was was kind
of hard
and you became head coach pretty quickly
to away yeah yeah but three years be an
assistant so so one was goof um one with
Dave Henderson and two with bread more
yeah
let's see a coach and I was sitting with
him in the following year head coach
which I think I was a bit bit naive
again today thinking yeah it's a it's a
big job being like it's and it's and I'd
only be coaching a few years
so looking back I was like man the
auction it happened pretty quick yeah
too quick yeah
um but yeah you learn from learn from
those experiences as much as you do the
good ones yeah and how was it with the
players obviously you were pretty good
mates with a lot of those guys you
played many years with them so then
having to have these tough conversations
with you know changing the culture and
these sort of things I know
um you're a great mates with Jamie
McIntosh who's been on the podcast and I
think was it you who made the decision
to sort of let him go from Southland
which must have been a pretty tough
conversation that was it was really
tough and in looking back
I didn't handle that as well as I could
have and it was you know like my
coaching age
um it was really tough tough that and
then still to this day I don't know if
I've got 100 right or or handled the
aftermath right I did I definitely
didn't handle the conversation with
Jamie Jamie well
um and there was because it was like it
was awkward I mean like it was it was
such a good mate yeah you know really
really good mate
um I played so much rugby with Whopper
and and um
and just to have that conversation
you know it was tough it was really
tough and then um and then also with
um because because Jamie was make he
done so much and I think I took that for
granted about how much he's actually
doing with the the team yeah and how
much she was driving everything but then
on the other side was no one was growing
you know like because no one was going
because that all just you know what
we'll take care of it in terms of the
leadership and yeah and you know all the
on-field off-field stuff you know like
because pop was all over it yeah and um
and so that's it was kind of part of
like most of the reason why I thought
well if we can get create more leaders
they're not going to grow yeah I don't
know whether I've got 100 right but you
know that's just you know you learn from
those from those situations how was he
in the combo how was he
now it was it was it was actually really
good
um I tried to yeah like it was it was
never about I think a lot of people
thought it was about Jamie as a person
but it was never about Jamie as a person
it was it was about what what I thought
was going to be right for the program at
that stage and that's where I might have
been a bit not even thinking that these
other boys are ready to step up into the
into the void that he'd Left Behind yeah
because it was massive I mean like he
was his his Mr stag okay
and it was tough it was tough he it was
like James James is a really really good
human and he'd do anything for anyone
yeah and that's why it was tough it was
tough it was still tough oh yeah I even
think about it now I'm just like far
around you know
it's just one of those things in rugby
that you know especially going to
coaching yeah yeah it sounds okay until
you have to have those conversations
with people and you know like leads that
you know you kind of especially when you
played with them I think like being in
that situation was tough because I
played so much rugby with Whopper like
Stags and Hondas and then who was the
who was the lucky candidate to take on
Mr stagg's route that was uh Braden
Mitchell a scripture
um have you done he done a really good
job with the tools and again like that's
me as a as a young head coach
Polly didn't set him up as well as I
could have too you know like thinking
back
there's a lot more things I could have
put in place to try but it was like man
like we had a we had a really young
inexperienced team down there and it was
um it was pretty tough on scratch pretty
stuff it was a tough couple of Seasons
Staffing it must have been tough on you
too hey like yank coach what was uh what
was the um region like about the
decision as well they obviously all
loved and Whopper were they all
supportive or did you cop a bit of heat
oh I copped a bit yep caught the bit
below that's
this is part of it yeah you know
um it's part of the game that we're in
and and people are passionate about it
and people are passionate about the
players too mate there was uh definitely
some backlash and there was some some
that just said well let's just get on
for it yeah like yeah did you have a
question coaching oh yep yep yep so a
couple of those couple of years or
especially after it because I've done a
couple of years head coach and then went
over to Japan
but before leaving you know I was like
man and my wife was watching me going
through all this yeah it was like tough
yeah there's a couple of Seasons down
there yeah and then we went over to um
Japan and and uh oh awesome hey this is
coaching
it's like
awesome fan yeah awesome new environment
totally yeah because I've been in the
Southland too the whole time and I think
going back down in coaching there was I
was still backing that that bubble and I
think down to a totally different
environment even like coming up here you
kind of you're away from all that and
you're just starting off a new sheet
yeah
so going over to um over to Honda with
with Denny and Craig and of course maybe
like three awesome years over there with
my fan family and totally different
culture and everything else work it how
did your kids find it because they were
a bit older at this point hey how did
they find living in Japan and school I
guess yeah so so they went to Japanese
school so by the time we left they were
three quarters fluent and read write and
and chat very very right yeah that's
awesome oh really really good they've
kind of lost a bit now we've been back
for 18 months but
um my girl went to
um the kindergarten over there so she'd
she knew a bit but they the first couple
of weeks going to school were a bit
tough because they went to a school
where no one spoke English
yeah we were kind of I was walking away
again
yeah this is yeah full-on for them yeah
and so they they guttered through it man
and they come out the other side and
they were awesome but it was such a safe
environment like they were walking to
school
every day for like they'll walk down the
street for 15 minutes yeah
big days for them that'll be leaving
about
7 30 getting home about 4 30. was that
the school hours
come home then I was homework and stuff
parents dream they get back here
now it's parents night I mean no
homework or anything like that though
that was cool for them cool for the um
for my wife
um this school was awesome experience
yeah and how'd you find the coaching
obviously
um it's a different rugby a and you're
working with different sort of athletes
so and how did you find it yeah it's it
is different
um
obviously the the language the language
barrier kind of hinders a few things but
but the more I felt the more language I
knew
the more they understood it and then the
easier it becomes because you're not
kind of waiting on because everything
takes twice as long during the
conversation
um you have to be quite directive in
what you're coaching so you have to have
your the basics really nailed down in
the detail around the basics
and they want to know
what I do here what I do here but what
if this happens what if this happens so
you kind of and we got to a good point
where we were kind of we got to the
point where we were like well that's
rugby you've got to make a decision yeah
about this and so you teach them the
different decisions they can make and
then they've got they got a lot better
and some of the things you just take
that decision away from them to say just
do that if this happens just do that
yeah just don't let that happen yeah and
they nod and they do it yeah yeah they
just get it done get it done the
foreigners and the team they kind of
like looking at you questioning like
this and you like to get it done yeah
it was interesting coaching that the
foreigners were quite oh we had a really
good Bunch good bunch of leads who'd you
have
um monola Mickey who's uh hi who's that
yes he's a he's a layer yeah good dude
um Sean treby baby
um Aiden TOA
um had a couple of cephalization there's
a couple stores in there with Matas
person
yeah it was good Duffy Matt Duffy sorry
Matt Duffy was there I'm probably gonna
feed a couple I'm not going to be at me
but um do you want Stickman
so it was like a really good crew and
they were they were all in yeah it was a
good match so why'd you leave
um oh kids are getting a bit older and
we're kind of wanted my boy to he was
going to be standing in high school soon
so yeah make some mates and then and
then come back
um so
yeah we uh uh decided to come back uh
his last year of primary school so you
could go into meeting and make some
friends and so we moved back to the next
we moved it to Blenheim so she was she
was all go and did he have any plans
when you moved there that was the
coaching gig part of that move no no so
we moved it we bought a property in
Blenheim and then
um it all kind of just just morphed into
into being here with my horses so much
fun how good oh it's awesome eh that's
that's like it's honestly it's a really
really special environment I got here
yeah how's it compared to obviously
you've been on a few how's it compared
to other environments oh it's like it's
right like those have so much this is so
much fun to be had here and then but
then once you step across the chalk it
kind of changes which is wicked I sent
the the culture that that's the parent
is one of the way they can challenge
each other but still kind of like have a
laugh too yeah yeah but it's just the
energy that's the difference I reckon
it's just the energy that's around you
know like oh it's fun right you get up
and everyone's every year they love it
but it's just like you know like the way
that the snc guys just do you know like
um the week there was yeah it's for the
boys and there's these little wee bits
and pieces that just keep you know keep
putting time into and it's special you
know I don't know if the boys realize
how especially I think the guys that
play Super I think they do because they
go away to these other violence and
and then they come back to listen you
can see the enjoyment that they have
coming back you know when they will turn
up and it's so accommodating yeah that's
what that's what I really enjoyed you
know it was so welcoming into
environments and that's just good fun
and you mentioned your Vineyard so
um how did that come about like had you
ever planned on getting into that no no
no I got well I've got a few cousins
over in Cleveland one of them's uh quite
easy into the industry and the city was
an opportunity to buy a house because
he's always talked about me moving up
and said there's an opportunity to get a
house up here and with some vines on it
so I thought
give it a crack and I come up and had a
few visits over during covert
um before we went back to Japan and then
yeah it all kind of worked out and
so we uh yeah we just moved back with uh
with a thing that just kind of maybe
live in a normal life yeah I didn't know
whether I was going to be coaching or
not you know like and then and just
having us in the background is just
chipping away and did you just learn on
the run or yeah yeah so so that um so he
he's got his own my cousin's got his own
Vineyard so I'd kind of work closely
with the clients manager in his
Vineyards and then he'd tell me what uh
so you can do this so we can pay someone
to do it so we try to do everything that
we can yeah certain things we can't
so they just kind of so you just pay the
bills on it and but it's it's pretty
cool yeah yeah it's really cool like and
especially in summertime when all the
leaves are out and stuff like that
around their house and stuff extremely
lucky yeah and where does uh where do
the grapes go like what do you do with
them do you I just sell them so they
they go into a co-op and they produce
wine oh yeah yeah but they they're all
our all the grapes pretty much get sent
over to States sorry it gets made into
wine here then let's go to our states
here Josie can't drink your wine in New
Zealand yeah you can yeah well no I've
got a few bottles I should have bought
you money I apologize I'll check it once
I'll try and sell some yeah
um but they um they do produce a little
bit but about 30 of that of that group
30 sold in New Zealand oh yeah
um yeah but seriously it goes over the
states but yeah so it's pretty cool
though it's like a co-op of all like
grape Growers
that uh we'll buy into into like a team
kind of environment which is cool so how
do you do it when you're coaching
obviously you're coaching over here at
Nelson living over in Blenheim your
vineyard's over in Blenheim so how does
it all work you're never over there no I
think most of it
um the good thing is it it's in the
season when it's off so there's not a
lot I can do during the rugby season
yeah
um but I teach my wife how to drive
because I want to check I bought a
tractor and then I had to learn how to
drive so I learned how to drive checked
out then this season I've had to teach
the wife how to drive a check done so we
can do stuff like with spraying under
the robes and stuff like that and mowing
the grass when it needs and so
man she's all over it she's a she's a
weapon oh how good yeah so it's time to
put my feet up
what is what is the plans for you
obviously um had Dan Perrin on a couple
of maybe months ago and
he told me he wanted to be a Crusaders
Coach and he's got that now so
um where does the coaching dreams take
you well I'm I'm loving what I'm doing
now yeah I'm loving one and I'm I'm not
really looking too far ahead well that's
easy I can make that happen
I'm not too sure you know like um it's a
it's a it's a Fickle old job coaching
you know like you know it is is 20
something players on the field but
there's only two coaches or three
coaches he understands so you know if
opportunities come up obviously I jump
at them but also we moved back from
Japan for a bit more family life so
they'll have to work in with it too yeah
so oh man oh I'm oh I just enjoy I'm
just enjoying what I'm doing at the
moment yeah it does get tough with kids
they like um if you do get it offer
overseas
um whether it is worth moving the family
and you know relocating like if a Japan
kid came up for a couple of years would
you take your kids or how that all works
yeah so they're at an age now we're a
bit quite tough to take them over like
overseas or something like that you know
like and um and I know and I know my
wife pretty Keen to set up routes but
you know when opportunities come as you
know
um you kind of it's pretty hard to turn
down yeah so there'll be a few
conversations and and everything has to
work into what to what you kind of need
you know I wouldn't jump at something
that I didn't think was going to be
beneficial for us as a family it's uh I
almost feel like coaching's a single
man's game eh yeah go wherever you want
or until your kids like so yeah yeah
until they're older yeah you finish
school or something like that and you
can kind of take off so but that's not
another 11 or so years for me you know
for my daughter so I don't know it's
it's as I said I'm enjoying what I'm
doing so long maybe continue mate and I
know tazzy love having you here so
anyway as always we've gone to our
questions
Instagram has Kevin humming with
questions for whom uh Tain Robinson sent
in plenty first question is how did you
get the nickname Hoon so obviously
that's a common name for you hey
everyone knows he was home yeah yeah uh
I think
there was or one
um I had a teacher this is when I was
like 11 intermediate she she couldn't
pronounce my name even though I was kind
of walking through it she just couldn't
get it and so she started calling me
um Hoon for some reason
huni or something like this and then I
was like oh well it's better than
butchering like you know yeah that'll do
less is and then that's when it kind of
checked out yeah I had a teacher I
couldn't pronounce Hawaii for some
reason I was gonna get it so and then
and then after that I think the boys
because even all my mates used to you
know growing up they always just call me
Hawaii but then
um playing sports and stuff like that
it's far easier to stay home than yeah
so that was just and it just stuck after
that sure right love it nickname Hoon
okay next one oh this one came from
Highlander's head coach Clark Germany
what'd you say to Nema tilata after one
scrum
oh that's that's awesome so we were
playing the Stags
the whole time with the Lions uh was
well full of Stags and then um we've
kind of put one on them and uh dominated
in the scram and I kind of hopped up I
started kind of Melvin off it
it in the mirror saying oh all black
mass
kicking the [ __ ] out and then I remember
Clark just turned around shut up you
know like and I was like look at him
like what Mommy you got me we got him
and then I remember just looking at me
and he's like just looking at our
steering wide-eyed and like okay and
then man he put us under the pump after
the game Clark just turned around don't
ever ever say anything
so it was quite a good listen learned
there well Clark he was under the pump
after that couple times just behind them
just cushioning why we're not dominating
but it push harder
oh that's good stuff okay next one
hardest opponent to tackle
uh
I played repeating a couple of times oh
yeah it's mannequin because I used to
find myself out there quite a bit did
you get one-on-one with them uh I was
one-on-one he was the one-on-one
had no chance he was
he was something else but um Seth is a
pretty mate he knew where they were
coming there so it was it was Connie
said to me enough I really enjoyed
playing surfingers because they just run
it straight so he knew without coming
that was the big guy like Big Fellas
like sioni lovakian and where they kind
of ran straight at you and then they can
put a bit of footwork and we'll just
yeah throw it around like a red ball
though he was tough yeah
good stuff okay best pro that you played
with
you would have played with some for us
yeah Clark was pretty professional
actually yeah yeah yeah I learned a lot
of Clark and it was weird because he was
younger than me oh yeah yeah so but he'd
been in professional long couple years
before me and he was he was right on a I
thought it could have fallen a bit more
it was a little bit more of my career
but he was he was
he was I so I always knew about Clark
because he was right on in terms of
having himself off the field and on the
field yeah always going to be a good
coach always going to be a coach
just real quite steady and very focused
so it was good okay
uh this one's from Corey Flynn have have
you managed to find the bottom of your
Deep Pockets in retirement what's that
sort of hey you always
um shouting the voice
I'm trying to like you know trying to
distilled it
it started in the like well mate I'm
always one if it's free it's me man and
um so what was the same if it's free
it's me and I'll take three so um uh it
was always kind of like so there'd be
free beers going along man I was always
in freebies yeah they had a few beers
and and I remember back in the day the
Valentine used to follow the ace oh yeah
yeah and then so but we'd always be done
before then so we'll always be up for
them to spend every place we went to
they had a bar tip at some place you
would find out about it it's real
drinking free beers and stuff like this
and I think they got a bit of grief with
us but
I don't know like um it's just something
that's kind of coming out of nowhere
really I'm always up for a bargain yeah
always up for a bag and you're silly if
you're not a lot yeah right I've lived
under that as well to be fair you know
it makes no sense to pay for beers if
you can get them free right no that's a
sense to pay for anything
you don't want to be stealing of course
but yeah he's he's always at me Corey
without being tight and I'm just sitting
here just to shake my head but it's
definitely a rumor that that has sped
around I'm trying to dispel it mate I
had another one from him is why are you
such a drinking game Nazi and I have
seen you in your element in this
yeah yeah that's another thing with our
Connor
oh my I enjoy the drinking game yeah and
uh yeah like rules are meant to be meant
to be kind of a babe mate
so uh I've always just enjoyed enjoy
playing drinking games or any game
really it's a kind of competing and it's
always and it's not just drinking games
mate if we're playing con games or
something like that yeah yeah I was I
was a trainer's nightmare yeah just Adam
yeah
um but
um the trekking games has always been
been a funny thing like when we were
first when I first started playing mate
it was massive you know and uh
I guess we play quite often and it was a
few beers but I got back one year and
then that no one wanted to play drinking
games and I was okay with it oh you know
like like I remember the coach coming up
to me
um the song that hadn't come up to me
and said I'm like boys I want to play
drinking games you know there was a big
thing now now because we were playing
Super so we missed the preseason stuff
because yeah boys don't want to play
drinking games and I was like yeah okay
and he's I'm looking like why well why
are you telling me this thing or you
were the one that that drives them while
I don't know what the same thing as yes
you are and I said I'm not I'm the one
that will play once someone starts
playing but I used to be an [ __ ] at
least my labels yeah and then the first
my first drink I've always just do label
on purpose yeah and I'll sit there and
like and then someone look like
okay but if I do it then we're playing
the whole night and they're like yeah
okay okay so then you know let's win the
game started but I remember our first
one of the first games away we had and
this is after the conversation about not
not um playing drinking games yeah and
so we're sitting at a pub and then
everyone's kind of sitting around saying
I need a little say and it was kind of
like
waiting waited on him but um I feel the
boys are like ah stuff this come on
let's just play some games
and so then after that you know I was I
said to I said mate this ain't me yeah
yeah but I'm I am a Nazi I am a Nazi
oh that's good stuff no drinking gas
between tough okay
this probably leads to that one best
off-field story from your time at the
stags from the Stags yep one of the best
ones was her case it was um
so we had a coin game so um so we're on
it in the season trip to Queenstown yeah
the boys on the bus and then um we pull
up pubs on the way up and say there was
a one coin it was dollar coin and um if
they've got a few holding your glass and
they got dropped in it and there's the
chop your glass and so and because I was
I was the Nazi the boys are asked me the
whole time the whole time and so then um
and I was sitting there then something
happened that I learned it was and
someone gave me a jug and so oh yeah and
they go yeah just hold it for me and
then I was kind of and I was I was kind
of I was a bit half cut and then so I
was just kind of holding it and I was
better grabbing my glass to pour it in
and then what would come up behind me
hit this coin and it dropped it and I
just like looked at it and he dropped it
and it hit the rim and then it fell off
the room and then it landed in The Jug
below it oh I'm sitting on the table and
I was swimming there and I looked at him
and he was looking at me and then it was
like well if I started cracking it
because obviously it's a door Jack
but they all laughed me ever since yeah
every every drinking trip yeah I'm like
a bit of a focus for the boys because
I'm such a I'm an [ __ ] I like that
song Hey I'm an [ __ ] but
now I was it was took one of our we had
so many trips away it's hard to kind of
find a favorite were you at the um the
famous Highlander do the one with Hesco
and Bucky and I went home so you're
playing that yeah
you're one of the two or three guys who
went there yeah the odd odd gone home I
think we had another we had a space
thing and then I I took off after the um
the do at the Spates Lounge yeah so I
just went home a bit older boy there no
time so
um but yeah but the next morning or when
I went and uh went to the I think we did
the team photo the next day yeah and we
were talking to Jimmy and it's like it's
all cut up and I said hey what's going
on
that sounds
okay kind of then also coming out and I
was just like the attitude but uh it was
like he's a good match to me yeah he
just kind of gets a bit of a bed wrap on
some of those things I think it caused a
lot of it but I thought I'll go I'll put
one in front Okay next one uh tips to
coming into a high level environment
um you know like what I like liked about
coming into Tasman is that they're very
accepting that anyone in their own kind
of personality
um you have to you have to toe the line
in terms of what the team wants and all
that but I think you know being yourself
is really important if you try to be
someone else sooner or later you'll get
not found out yeah but it just won't
work yeah no you know like because it's
not you and so that's what I've really
enjoyed about coming in into Tasman they
said they are very accepting of people
in a different way they they kind of
operate yeah
there's certain things that you have to
do but you know like um
mate as long as you put the work in and
you're doing doing your job both on and
off the field then that's a big one for
me really like that
okay next one this uh question is from
our major sponsor swish uh one of the
great sponsors video shout out from any
celebrity in the world who would it be
and why mate I'm a big Michael Jordan
fan Michael Jordan oh mate he's like
yeah something else that is kind of a
like growing up yeah so if it was anyone
um the goat to think that you
potentially could have played with them
if you went down that gym
this is what the sweet office bro
he's he's someone that I've always
admired and looked up to
um and you know like I have an argument
with my mates because I think LeBron
James pretty good too yeah he's right up
there but Michael Jordan still the gate
oh LeBron's overtaking and has it this
record's hard to have to deny me but
it'll be you know like people will have
opinions on us they do that dude man
like he's LeBron he's just
he said like well I think we've had this
conversation of like my question would
be do you who's the greatest athlete of
all time
yeah
but like you know I remember oh so hard
it's impossible well you
size but can move like a ballerina and
jump as high as you know like like a
physical Phenom yeah and you know like
I'm like oh who could you who could do
like I try to think who would be a
better athlete than that guy I just
reckon he's been gifted some natural
talents here yeah harder than I
that's that's yeah what about someone
like Usain Bolt like obviously he's just
physically Next Level speed apparently
he's quite good at like cricket and
things like that yeah but he obviously
hasn't focused on those Sports he's just
been trying to run as fast as he can but
someone like him he must come in the
conversation yep yep hundreds they've
all they really thought he was saying
they said okay yeah we could probably
talk for hours through the greatest
athletes of all time it could be the
next next podcast but we will crack on
because it's more editing for me anyway
next question uh what's something that
you've seen hold back players careers
more than anything else it's interesting
man a bit deeper yeah well one is how
they and I I wasn't the same off the
field but definitely how the hell boys
connect themselves off the field yeah
you know like the the game the game is
now the skin like when when I was
playing
professionally it was
like 10 less than 10 years into being in
a professional sport
yeah listen 10 years and be a
professional sport now it's what are we
into almost 30. so the game's moved and
so the things that you that we used to
do back then you kind of realize now
certainly we're way off yeah
what we're putting in our bodies yeah
before and after games and everything
like that yeah and now like for me just
if you want to be a professional
you've got to behave like a professional
and and it's not just a
game day thing is it's a lifestyle of
it's your job and your tools are your
body so the more that you look after
your body and and
preparing yourself for that game it can
only
help you so in terms of holding you back
if you're not doing it now yeah you know
like you and people question our health
I'm not making these teams I'm not
making 23 yeah or the the stats and
everything that lie yeah all your
numbers don't lie you've gotta you know
so I think it's their field stuff is
holding people back more than anything
right that said I'm still I'm still
surprised at how many guys don't sort of
you know fully invest into themselves
and their career like and we've seen it
but this year but
um you know you got an opportunity of a
lifetime to sort of make a career out of
the game and
um to just you know eat it and drink it
or you know it's it's quite hard to
watch yeah it's really I think the next
you know like especially when you're
coaching now and you kind of see it I
think as a player you kind of oh no it's
just it's like I'm getting paid yeah
yeah that's my job but I absolutely
they're fine and yeah you know it's like
a game but but if you weren't doing that
you'd be
on the tools doing something maybe
working you'll be laboring you'll be in
the office or something like that and
and as I said no I didn't treat it as
professional as what I what I should
have but looking at now like the
opportunities to be a professional
Sportsman really small so you've got to
grab at me and like and the careers
careers are getting shorter I reckon
yeah
so the more the quicker you can grab on
to say and commit to being an official
rugby player
the more success you're going to have
another I firmly believe that yeah 100
love that okay last question best piece
of advice you have for a woodland
listener you've already given us a
little bit already so could be good oh I
think
often be yourself I've said it before
it's a bit yourself be true to yourself
and it was something that I've learned
especially kind of the coaching I think
when I first started coaching I wasn't
you know for me personally I would think
I was trying to be someone else
and I wasn't myself
so I think uh everyone in looking back
when you reflect you kind of understand
all this but you know if you if you're
trying to be someone else and sooner or
later you're gonna get found out so just
be who you are and if it doesn't work
well that it is what it is yeah yeah
like as a player you're you know you go
from a player to a coach quite quickly
you're yourself as a player and then all
of a sudden you still want to be
yourself but as a coach and how that
personality has to change or whether it
does have to change and that's I find
that like uh almost like a gray area as
a going from a player to a coach unless
we all think I battled when I was down
the Southland yeah because I played with
that group too I've gone from playing
with them into actually coaching
and then you know like having
conversations you know it's weird man
like having a conversation with the
coach
and he's talking about the players yeah
you know the conversation about players
yeah funny yeah like when you switch the
side they're certainly like it's quite
like that rigged in it was kind of like
harsh what do you say about me it's
always something
but like situation like that I'll be
involved in that hey what you love me
with me
right but you know like and that's the
part that I think is really hard you
know to be yourself still in that in
that Arena because obviously your your
perspective changes
especially when you're going to coaching
and stuff like that it's a bit of
changes on players and how they should
conduct themselves and then if you can
beat yourself
that's it and make what an episode one
of the great episodes of what allowed
with the great Hawaii McDonald who has
had some career I mean dying on the
field
unbelievable story like how you've uh
gone through your career and played for
all the teams you did had the successful
career on the field and then Post 40 as
well coaching it's been it's been a
privilege um coaching with you this year
with Tasman and I really enjoyed your
company and um working with you so
um looking forward to following what's
next for you and hopefully any of more
success around the corner thank you mate
it's been a pleasure working with you
two
um very welcoming and the whole group
really that's why I just love my time
here and thanks for having me out here
and
all right thanks for coming out to the
studio absolutely first party done love
your work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]